In Japan, International Olympic Committee chief Thomas Bach and Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe...
...reached a preliminary deal to postpone the Tokyo Olympic Games until 2021...
...amid overwhelming international pressure.
In India, Prime Minister Narendra Modi...
...ordered a 21-day lockdown of the world's second most populous country on Tuesday...
...to halt the spread of coronavirus.
Authorities in China said...
...they will end a two-month lockdown of most of virus-affected central Hubei province at midnight,...
...as domestic cases of the virus continue to subside.
Deaths from the new coronavirus in Iran rose by 122, bringing the toll to 1,934 fatalities,...
...Iranian authorities said Tuesday, as the worst outbreak in the Middle East continues to unfold.
Finally from Britain, home appliances firm Gtech, which specializes in making vacuum cleaners,...
...has made a prototype of a medical ventilator,....
...which founder Nick Grey says can be scaled to mass production within weeks...
....to help in the fight against COVID-19.